the unification of Germany in the midst
of the franco-prussian war changed
Europe forever its creation importantly
involved the annexation of the region
known as our sus Lorraine or else a slew
during an in German which permanently
damaged franco-german relations when
thinking about Alsace Lorraine there is
one question that is seldom asked what
was life like for the French people who
already lived there by French I simply
mean the people who lived in France
prior to the annexation not
french-speaking people since in these
areas German was the dominant language
that said whilst the majority of the
AMEX Territory spoke German that didn't
necessarily mean that they wanted to
join Germany for the Germans there was a
lot of debate over what was to be done
with their new territory it was decided
that the territory would be centrally
run from Berlin as what's called a
Reich's land meaning that the Kaiser
held direct authority there although he
did act through a governor at first our
SAS Lorraine had zero input into its own
affairs but by 1879 it had been granted
some concessions so for the average
French person who lived in the region
since before 1871 what changed well in
the immediate aftermath of the war the
people living there were given a choice
leave within a year or become Germans
and of the 1.5 million inhabitants there
about 50,000 people left for France the
overwhelming majority of Alsace Lorraine
population was Catholic and it now being
ruled mostly by the Protestant Prussians
meant that there were going to be
tensions in the end Catholics were
barred from higher education and their
newspapers were heavily censored this
meant that from then on the Catholics
would have an extremely strained
relationship with the German government
hence why it's incorrect to boil
resistance to German rule down to little
more than Frenchmen not liking it was
the cultural shock of being ripped away
from France was unquestionably severe
the economic hit was absolutely massive
for example Alsace produced more cotton
textiles than the entirety of Germany
combined in 1871 and it now being cut
off from France meant that they had no
more customers and that German textiles
now faced tremendous competition this
competition to German textiles were so
bad it was proposed that in order to
mitigate this Alsace be given to
Switzerland instead but shockingly the
Kaiser said no so after 40 years was the
region fully integrated not really
whilst the region had gained some
autonomy over the years its people
wanted more in 1913 German soldiers
insulted the local population using the
term vac as a derogatory term for the
people of Alsace Lorraine iam what's
called there's a Bern incident this led
to protests and the kaiser wilhelm ii
subsequently sided with the soldiers
which basically destroyed any loyalty
the region had to the empire when the
first world
war broke out a year later sympathies
for France remained high as such army
conscripts from Alsace Lorraine was sent
to the Eastern Front so that the divided
loyalties wouldn't be tested furthermore
speaking French in public was banned and
the people of the region were treated
poorly since the government was worried
about pro-french spies and ultimately
after French victory in the First World
War the region was returned to France
and the issue over who owned it was
totally settled forever I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching and a special thanks to all of
these patrons you see on screen for
their generosity in supporting the show
and a particularly special thanks to
James Bissonnette party-boy Co kazarka
flash Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker
Michael Reynolds Thomas McGill Gustav
Swan Winston Hayward Skye Chappell the
amusement park Ives Adam Harvey
and lastly rafail